I was shocked by how many people at FBI
were at Twitter I mean we're not talking
just low-level people although they were
they were there too but we're talking
the former general counsel to FBI this
is like one of the most senior
Executives we're talking the Deputy
Chief of Staff I discovered a set of
other extremely troubling uh behaviors
including by former FBI Executives
including the former general counsel the
FBI who was then the second the deputy
general counsel within Twitter basically
you know him arguing for censoring the
laptop within Twitter and this is the
same person who was involved in
initiating the whole Russia gate the FBI
investigation of trump in the first
place when he was at Twitter we know
that there was that FBI and and the
intelligence agencies organized a little
group of all the social media companies
and they would have regular meetings
particularly in the run-up to elections
the the journalists themselves are
behaving in really weird Behavior I mean
when you imagine journalists get
together to talk about how not to cover
an issue or how to kind of squelch an
issue you know so that by the time the
Hunter buying laptop came out they had
all been mentally programmed to view it
as this information
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is the
author of a number of books and the
co-founder of the Public Sub stack
publication which I read almost every
day Michael schellenberger welcome back
to trigonometry good to be with you guys
again uh it's great to have you on
listen uh we obviously had the first
conversation with you and people can go
back and watch that to talk about San
Francisco your book and and things like
that but tell us what you've been up to
since we last spoke because uh you've
been doing quite a lot of good
journalistic work particularly the
Twitter files which we'll talk about uh
what have you been up to
yeah I mean the big news personally is
that I was under contract to do two
additional books one on nuclear energy
and then a third for harpercollins that
was sort of going to be the last of a
series on
the ways in which civilized
civilizations undermine themselves from
within which is uh kind of where
apocalypse never in San Francisco ended
up and I I just gave back both book
advances because I decided that I wanted
to be writing full-time on sub stack I
just love the I love being in the news I
love publishing on topics that are in
the news I think it's a really great way
to you know for me it's good personally
I love the investigative work and I love
we're doing this kind of combination of
investigative and then we do explanatory
journalism after that and then we also
have a fair amount of you know trying to
inspire people about some more positive
project and not just be totally negative
so my friend Layton Woodhouse joined and
since January 1st it's been we are now
just doing public
uh at sub stack full-time and then I'm
also continuing to do work through with
my research organization environmental
progress really working on two big
campaigns the first is to have a much
stronger response to the addiction
driven homelessness crisis which is
particularly acute in the west of the
United States but is also in other big
cities and then the other is to protect
endangered species that are being
threatened by industrial renewable
energy projects particularly a large
industrial Wind Farm off the coast of
the East Coast which threatens the North
Atlantic right whale of which there's
only 340 left in the world and they can
experience no more population declines
without risk of Extinction
the whooping cranes which are threatened
by big wind transmission projects in the
in the Midwest and the desert tortoises
in California which are threatened by a
big industrial well not one but many
industrial solar projects
so that's what I'm up to and it's we're
having a great time and you know as you
guys know we were involved in the
Twitter files I've also been a big
critic of the world economic Forum so
I'm excited to get into those topics
with you guys well we're going to talk
to you about both the the cabal of pedo
lizards or whatever whatever it is at
Davos but first let's talk about the
Twitter files because
um I I don't know what happened exactly
I I spent quite a bit of time going why
is no media covering this but it was
literally a complete blackout and if you
just watched the BBC CNN if you read the
Times the telegraph the the whatever you
would not have had any idea that any of
this was happening so first of all tell
us what what the Twitter files reveal
what were they about and secondly what
does this mean
sure so um everyone knows that Elon Musk
the founder of Tesla and SpaceX bought
Twitter at a much inflated price he told
us that he probably paid about three
times more than it was worth he's taken
over the company it's been a chaotic
situation by his account
um trying to figure out the algorithms
and he wanted to have a fresh start so
he invited in a number of journalists
to basically go through the emails and
internal records of Twitter Executives
to understand how Twitter was responding
on some pretty big events I was brought
in by my friend Barry Weiss who runs the
sub stack publication the Free Press I
was a bit of an odd choice in the sense
that I was the only one of the
journalists involved that have ever
explicitly criticized Elon Musk in print
I've done so actually for almost a
decade including in Mother Jones
magazine but also I criticized his
statements around solar panels in
Apocalypse never so some of the people
kind of jump to some assumptions that he
Cherry that he picked us picked each of
us that's not the case when I met him he
said he didn't know didn't know who I
was
so if that's true then he wasn't cherry
picking the reporters and even if he did
know who I was and he was picking
somebody who had been a Critic of his
we had pretty free access to the files
we would ask for searches related to
particular topics time periods and
executives
and the big picture is just that many of
the things that people had suspected
that there was a explicit throttling or
what they call de-amplification in
popular parlance is called Shadow
Banning that was definitely occurring
with disfavored voices
certainly with with people right of
Center it was occurring but it was also
occurring with critics of the covid
lockdowns with vaccine mandates you know
some of the most egregious was having I
mean here you have
Twitter Executives responding under
pressure from the White House
or from just other Advocates including
CDC and others to basically censor or
label tweets by people with reasonably
different points of view on covid
mandates to give you one example Martin
kildorf at Harvard University tweeted
you know not everybody needs to get a
vaccine you know particularly young kids
like zero to five don't don't probably
need it maybe the most reasonable thing
one could say about the vaccine he was
not suggesting that vaccines are
involved in some conspiracy I think he
even says that some people you know that
people should get them and it was
labeled by by Twitter by people at
Twitter who frankly were not nearly as
qualified as Martin kildorf I was
involved in I did two uh Twitter threads
the first on the decision to de-platform
president Trump and then the second on
the decision to censor the hunter Biden
laptop so those are the two topics I
know best these are topics I had not
written on before and so there was the
on the one hand
um a kind of Crash Course on learning
both issues and then also I think
bringing
what Buddhists call beginner's Minds to
those topics which was something that as
I've gotten older I've come to
appreciate more because there's a shock
when you see what's going on that I
think people that are more jaded that a
minute no longer don't have
and the first is I think the key thing
for people to understand about both is
that the internal Twitter staff analysis
both of the hunter Biden laptop and of
the Trump tweets that got him banned
from the platform the internal decision
was that they had not violated Twitter's
own terms of service in other words the
the staff looked at it and went all the
way up to the head of of trust and
safety and they said these were tweets
that were not in violation of Twitter's
rules
so they changed the rules in order to be
able to achieve the objective first of
de-platforming trump and then of
censoring Hunter Biden's laptop now I am
a bit more sympathetic to the position
that there's some amount of content
moderation that must occur inside these
platforms for reasons but good and bad
um but there is some content moderation
I occur so I'm not suggesting that
there's no content moderation
and I'm also I also think the fact of
the matter is these guys were just
making up the rules as they went and
there's no other way it could be because
there were no rules and and rules were
also being adjusted to real world events
and that's also understandable so not so
the fact that they changed rules is in
itself not necessarily problematic
however in the case of the Trump
de-platforming my view and this is now I
think probably a majority or mainstream
view at least among certainly the
um Jack Dorsey the former CEO and
founder of Twitter shares this view is
that they should not have de-platformed
him and that they really had many tools
at their disposal to be able to control
what Trump was saying including taking
down uh tweets including giving him a
kind of time out what they call bouncing
somebody and that that decision was not
justified and had really serious
ramifications where you're taking
obviously the head of the Free World the
someone who is democratically elected
and not allowing them to communicate in
ways that uh you know really they should
arguably be able to communicate at least
if they're not in Gross violation and it
seems to me that Twitter violated The
public's trust in that decision the
other decision I think was even more of
a violation and that was the decision to
to uh censor effectively the hunter
Biden laptop Story by the New York Post
on October 14th
excuse me
um this was a decision of course that
also CEO Jack Dorsey said was the wrong
decision it was a decision that they
reversed nonetheless what's important
about the episode is that the censorship
of the piece and then the and other
things going on including Former
Intelligence uh Community
Representatives
claiming that the laptop was probably a
result of Russian disinformation and and
Facebook censoring of the piece and
widespread enunciations of the laptop
Story by others in the news media all
contributed to the perception that the
laptop's information was not legitimate
uh you know if you I mean I I reason I'm
so confident of that is because that's
how I viewed it personally and that's
how other people viewed it at the time
including my family members they did not
think that this was they were all
Democrats who do not think that this is
uh that the laptop was legitimate or
that it was pointing to legitimate
information
and moreover I discovered a set of other
extremely troubling uh behaviors
including by former FBI Executives
including the former general counsel the
FBI who was then the second the deputy
general counsel within Twitter
um basically you know him arguing for
censoring the laptop within Twitter and
this is the same person who was involved
in initiating the whole Russia gate the
FBI investigation of trump in the first
place when he was at Twitter there's a
lot of FBI people in Twitter engaging
activities that we still don't totally
understand we also saw what was a kind
of pre-bunking effort to discredit the
hunter Biden laptop before it became
publicly known by FBI agents going to
Twitter and Facebook and warning that
there would be potentially a hack and
leak operation by Russians
um that would involve Hunter Biden and
it's important to understand that FBI
had the hunter Biden laptop
um in December 2019 so almost a full
year before the the laptop was coming
out you have FBI warning Twitter and
Facebook of some sort of a leak
operation
I'm not saying I don't have proof that
there was a conspiracy by existing and
former FBI agents to discredit the
hunter Biden laptop knowingly in order
to help Biden and hurt Trump but there
is a pattern of behavior that is so
suspicious
that is so uh bizarre and weirdly
coincidental that it merits
Congressional investigation and that is
of course or maybe not of course but
that is what is occurring now in
Congress is that they are taking a look
at this pattern of behavior but at a
minimum which you have is the entire
intelligence community
a many private actors including some
funded by the federal government most
Democrats and others whipping up an
absolute hysteria around Russian
influence operations they call them they
used to call them psychological
operations or misinformation campaigns
and there was never any very good
evidence that much was occurring after
2016. and even in terms of 2016 it
wasn't uh that there was a lot of
Russian misinformation that reached the
American people the main event was its
role in uh hacking the DNC and John
podesta's emails and generating media
attention
so there was at best grotesque threat
inflation of Russian disinformation
and I think some confusion around what
that means along with a kind of
um
you know constant escalation of what was
meant by Russian misinformation you know
as Martin gurie who uh is the author of
Revolt of the public which I think is
one of the best books ever written on
the internet points out you should want
to know what Russians think like you
should want to know what Iranians think
the idea that if Iranians are making the
Iranian government like the people we
may not like are making their views
known in the United States and in in
ways that you could potentially label
misinformation you know if the Iranians
are saying you know
um all gays and lesbians should be
persecuted
um like we don't agree with that I don't
know that you wouldn't call that exactly
misinformation but you had this
constantly expanding definition and this
wasn't just in the research I did but in
others that would then allow FBI and
other agencies to play an absolutely
inappropriate role of pressuring the
social media companies to censor content
that they didn't like sensory users who
were not linked to the Russians in any
way whatsoever but were saying similar
things or engaged in similar kind of
arguments you hear this kind of creeping
uh you know McCarthyism I would say all
the time where people people say to me
they go well you're saying what you're
saying sounds like something the fossil
fuel companies would say well I mean
it's like the kind of classic you know
who else had who like German Shepherds
Hitler liked Germans you know so you
would sort of get this widening view of
misinformation as this like Menace this
kind of Boogeyman that I think merits
significant investigation and then the
final thing I'll say for me that came
out of it was just that there has to be
transparency on content moderation and
I've told this to Elon as well by the
way and and hopefully he does it he
hasn't yet but there have to be
transparency around what the decisions
that are being made and how they're
being made it's absolutely not
proprietary it needs to be a condition
of the right that is established in U.S
law for these social media companies to
operate with liability from things like
lawsuits for sharing copywritten
information or slanderous material it's
known as section 230
of the communications decency Act
um that that needs they need to have
transparency about how these decisions
are made and I say this to somebody that
has been personally censored by Facebook
for writing accurate information about
forest fires that the the Facebook
sensors argued would be misleading that
there was misleading because it could
lead people to believe things that they
didn't want them to believe that's a
very slippery slope and I
unrelated to Twitter it was a piece um
of a email from Facebook Executives
telling the White House under pressure
from White House and and showing the
White House saying we have been
censoring accurate information about the
covid vaccines because of the concern
that people will draw conclusions from
it that we don't like namely to not get
the vaccination so that's a very
dangerous thing when you have people
censoring accurate information because
they're concerned what people might be
doing with it it's also potentially
dangerous to censor inaccurate
information in situations where counter
speech we're simply participating in the
discourse and the dialogue of debunking
things is much better I'm not saying you
can always do that it seems like most
platforms do not want to allow for
example Kanye West to post the swastika
and have that next to the advertiser
content you know um because the Versace
doesn't want to see its handbag
advertised next to a swastika so I I get
that but but we're talking about issues
of major public importance covid climate
change
whether the D platformer president
whether whether the president is
involved in his son's business dealings
these are things are absolutely in the
public interest and the and the uh the
we should err on the side of more not
less information and when they are
making censorship decisions they just
need to be public about it they need to
be transparent about it it needs to be
someplace where people can see what
those decisions were and why they were
made
Michael were you shocked by what you
found out with the Twitter files because
I remember reading it when it was first
released and I couldn't believe it the
the FBI the CIA now look I'm half South
American this is what you do to my
culture of my country I didn't expect it
to happen with the FBI to its own people
yeah for sure I mean like you know the
way that people dismiss the Twitter
files is they said well we always knew
there was content moderation going on
first of all nobody had any idea that
this amount of censorship was going on
of legitimate speech that's just a fact
it was simply not reported there was no
evidence anything where it was just
suspicions and they were being dismissed
as conspiracy theories by the mainstream
news media and others who wanted to see
more censorship by the social media
platforms but yeah I mean there is
something there's multiple shocks I mean
the first one is just to see how often
FBI was asking for content to be
um for users to be investigated the kind
of normalization of FBI and other
intelligence agencies interacting with
senior Twitter Executives I will say in
particular there were some cases where
there were Twitter Executives who I
think behaved nobly
um Joel Roth is somebody who was the
head of trust and safety at Twitter and
he was demonized kind of early on in the
Twitter files process but there were
many times where he pushed back against
the intelligence agencies however he did
ultimately cave in on two of the big
issues I view Joel Roth as a very
interesting kind of company man you know
like he was kind of a real professional
but it shows the limits of what real
professionals do in situations where
they're under really intense pressure
and all the way to the point where I was
describing where you see the the
Facebook Executives sort of being like
Oh please White House see how good of a
job we've done censoring content on
vaccines so that's very very shocking I
was shocked by how many people at FBI
were at Twitter I mean we're not talking
just low-level people although they were
they were there too but we're talking
the former general counsel to FBI this
is like one of the most senior
Executives we're talking the Deputy
Chief of Staff that's arguably the third
most important person I mean both of
them are arguably the third most
important people at FBI when you really
understand how political the director is
and how and and the kind of the lack of
clarity we have about whether things are
being compartmentalized or not it is
shocking to give you one example I mean
just to come back to the laptop there's
this problem in intelligence agencies
where we know after during 9 11 on the
run up to 9 11 that there were people in
intelligence agencies who knew that an
attack on the Twin Towers was being
planned but they were so compartment
analyzed or stove piped that that
information didn't get to the right
people so this huge effort after 9 11 to
go and not and to go and break down
those stove pipes that's why they part
of the reason they created the
Department of Homeland Security well
here you have a situation where FBI is
in the possession of the hunter Biden
laptop on the one hand and there are
other FBI agents who are telling
Facebook and Twitter that there could be
a leak a Russian Hack and leak operation
of information relating to Hunter Biden
that is extremely suspicious now
response the mainstream response would
be well that's okay because those those
that's compartmentalized the people who
were warning of the Russian
disinformation probably had no idea or
had no idea that the that they had the
hunter Biden laptop but then that raises
other concerns like like if you have the
hunter Biden laptop and you've got
people going around they're saying oh we
have Russian in disinfo on on Hunter
Biden wouldn't you want to know that
other people in the agency had the
hunter Biden laptop that's an important
question that would need to be asked
nobody's asked it no one's investigated
it so I found that really shocking
um you know I mean there's other stuff
that I think other people found shocking
like the level of just Conformity and
unanimity around issues like gender
ideology around the around the kind of
conflating of conservative views with
um hate speech
um the kind of conflating of questioning
whether the vaccine is is appropriate
for everybody with vaccine
misinformation or denial that surprised
me less because I I live in the San
Francisco Bay Area
[Laughter]
you know I mean it is like I think
Matt's Ivey posted I think I reposted
something like it was like 90 98 or 99
of Twitter staff political donations are
to Democrats so I mean the culture is
just monolithically hegemonically woke
so that surprised me less but definitely
the engagement of the intelligence
agencies I found rather shocking and
disturbing
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean executed for not
being real men which is correct well for
those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
Michael one of the things that uh I find
very very concerning indeed you've
talked a little bit about it but it's
it's the collusion between government
intelligence agencies and big tech
companies to the point where it's kind
of hard to know where one ends another
begins because there will be a revolving
door between them and uh you know I I
didn't realize America was a country in
which the White House told
you know journalists what they're
allowed to say in the public space which
is effectively what happened right
yeah absolutely
um yes so this is there's a lot to
unpack actually in that so we have uh
Supreme Court rulings that are basically
there to prevent the and there's a lot
of them over hundreds of years right so
it's it's not
um I'm not going to say the final word
on it but generally you don't we don't
allow the federal government to uh
exercise undue pressure on on people to
to censor their speech so then the
question is kind of what is that because
of course uh the people that work at the
government the president the the press
secretary the heads of different
agencies they have speech rights too and
so they can go out and they can say
Facebook shouldn't publish this you know
so you kind of go are you free to say
that you know
um you kind of go well I guess so I'm in
the sense that they can kind of say they
say the New York Times you know
shouldn't say that or the Washington you
just sort of that's what politicians do
and we have we actually give politicians
and elected officials quite a bit of
freedom of speech for themselves
you know you so it's also so I guess
it's more of a kind of you know the
definition of pornography as you know
when you see it when you see the White
House doing I'll give you this this
really specific kind of series of events
you see the White House and members of
Congress threatening to take away
from Facebook and Twitter this section
230 provision which means that they
which is basically what a lot the legal
basis for the existence of social media
companies if
um Washington posts make some outrageous
accusation against me and it harms me I
can sue
um those laws are obviously much more uh
strong in Britain than the United States
but we still have the same rules if
somebody does that on Twitter I can ask
Twitter to take it down but but Twitter
is not responsible for that that's a big
difference between a traditional media
organization and a media platform so
when you start getting so so you can see
how how quickly and how easily you move
from The New York Times is wrong when
they said that to Facebook shouldn't you
know or Twitter shouldn't publish that
New York Post piece you're moving from
media to platform and most people just
are regular experience of it we don't
experience those as sort of different
things it's kind of like yeah I go read
Twitter I read the New York Times these
are all the same thing you get them sort
of threatening to take away that section
230 because of concerns around so-called
vaccine misinformation and then it's
Relentless and there's other people that
were just more aggressive there's this
guy in particular Andy slavitt who's
just a demagogic activist
Zealot frankly demanding that this guy
Alex Berenson who by the way I mostly
don't agree with or maybe I agree with
him on like 50 of his writings just
demanding that he'd be deep platform
from Twitter which they did
um baronson actually sued and so we
actually have all of his internal
information from Twitter from his
lawsuit and we were able to see how it
related to the stuff that we saw but you
see them pressuring that or saying to
Facebook you've got to stop this
accurate information about vaccines from
spreading because it could lead to
vaccine hesitancy you kind of go that
just like you know it has to get in
front of a court and there is court
cases on it but I just think as an
ordinary you kind of go that crossed the
line you know that sort of population of
events it's not to say it's always going
to cross the line or that there's some
easy thing but you kind of go this
intense pressure particularly to censor
accurate information and with the threat
of taking away what is the legal basis
of these corporations strikes me as
potential First Amendment violations
right uh and Michael the other thing I
wanted to ask you is in this situation
one of the big concerns for me uh is
that we know for a fact that the all of
these social media companies not just
Twitter but Facebook and you know
obviously Instagram which is owned by
Facebook and and others they would meet
together and come up with strategies so
it's not an act accident that Donald
Trump was deep platformed from several
things at once right so is it reasonable
to assume that what was happening at
Twitter and we now know what was
happening in Twitter because a guy that
wasn't part of the system bought it is
almost certainly what was happening at
Facebook and what was happening at
YouTube and probably continues to happen
on on those platforms
oh yeah absolutely and we know that
there was that FBI and and the
intelligence agencies organized a little
group of all the social media companies
and they would have regular meetings
particularly in the run-up to elections
and just as a kind of I'm a trained
Anthropologist and so as an
anthropologist you kind of go what
they're sort of doing is they're kind of
trying to create a culture and the
culture they're trying to create and is
or sort of a tribe you know and they're
trying to and we know how that works
psychologically right so you're starting
to kind of get this inappropriate levels
of identification with the intelligence
agencies we're sort of like all of us
good people on the side of protecting
the you know the children you know the
public it's very paternalistic from this
dangerous misinformation from malevolent
actors you know that was kind of the
picture that they're sort of trying to
construct deliberately or accidentally
that's sort of coming from these
intelligence agencies it's also coming
from these frankly very suspicious and
in many cases is noxious Bad actors who
are private
organizations receiving Federal funding
includes the Stanford internet
Observatory an organization called
Graphica some of them did some probably
okay work but they were involved in this
thing of like there's something really
fundamentally wrong where it's like you
kind of go I say with journalists too
they go oh I'm an expert on
misinformation
it's like no you're 25 years old
you know like you don't have any you
can't just go and be like I'm an expert
in all misinformation I mean like it's
so weird when you think about it it's
sort of like I'm the truth teller you
know I'm here to and you guys are all
suspicious it's like I worked on like
apocalypse never my book on the
environment was literally 20 years of
life experience it has 1200 footnotes
you can imagine it's like you might
disagree with it or whatever we can
disagree over the evidence but you go
and have some you know uh in like just
someone that is doesn't know the topic
at all they're basically just going
they're allowing basically special
interest to then control what is
allowable and it was so I don't even get
it's not like I even get to have a
debate with my with my Star Chamber Of
accusers You know I try to appeal their
censorship of me and they said it would
go talk to the sensor I mean the
Inquisition had a better appellate
process than that you know so you you
sort of get this kind of creepy
organization of this kind of Star
Chamber or Star Chambers and then like
you said yeah there's people revolving
in and out it's both from the government
to the social media companies to these
non-profits that are funded by the
government
you get a strong alliance with the
Democrats and the Senate who are really
trying to control it I'm not saying
there weren't some bad things done by
Republicans even Trump when he was
president
um but it was clearly coming from the
woke Progressive National Security left
as strange as that may seem
it's it's such a bizarre thing and also
as well Michael the thing that I find
really troubling about
the about this entire story is that it
didn't get
basically the response that it deserved
and there's a part of me thinking do you
think that this is just going to go away
and we're never going to really find out
the answer and there's going to be a
cover-up
well that's a very interesting question
so I mean if you look at how it's
developing there's so many different
kind of threads here as well but so so I
mean I think we know like historians you
know I've done a lot of stuff on nuclear
as you guys know like after World War II
and whatever and it's like there's just
a lot of information would come out
decades later and years later so as a
historian you look back you do have some
confidence that more and more
information will come out and so we're
still in early days right I mean Elon
just we were just there in December so
yeah like two months less than two
months from when we started looking
through the files you have Congressional
investigations beginning
and then there's other things that are
sort of there's other things that are
not exactly like investigative work like
I was making a big deal of we're working
on a piece that we're going to publish
today about a major four-part Series in
the Columbia journalism review which is
like the most important kind of
journalist magazine in the United States
in part because it's at Columbia
University which gives out the Pulitzer
Prize which is our highest journalism
award it was a four-part series just
absolutely just trashing the media's
coverage of alleged Trump Russia
collusion sometimes called Russia gate
that piece was I mean for me too it just
was sort of game changing in the ways in
which it not only debunked a lot of that
stuff because some of it had been
debunked already but the way it kind of
put it together and exposed how the
media was doing it so Francis I guess an
answer to your question I'm actually
pretty confident that more information
is going to come out
um through these investigations and
other investigations I also think that
you sort of of like because there was a
thing where we were sort of just trying
to kind of there's a way because like
people were like how did it work and it
was like it was kind of a smash and grab
operation at Twitter you know we'd be
like can we need these files and you get
these files and you're going through
them in because people were like were
they filtering the files for you and
there was no way I mean they were giving
us these huge like they just didn't have
enough staff barely to do the searches
and they were giving them to us and they
were kind of going through them and
Reporting on them but it's taken me some
time and I've got more to say about it
of what I think some of the implications
are and and like and how these things
kind of were connected to each other
over time you know one of the things I
discovered in in the Twitter files was
that the Aspen Institute had organized
what they call a tabletop exercise which
is like a workshop that included the
heads of trust and safety at Facebook
and Twitter the top National Security
journalists at the New York Times in the
Washington Post to basically do an
exercise about how to how to not cover
um a Russian leak of information
relating to Hunter Biden they did it on
a phone call and in person I believe in
August and October and it was the
weirdest I mean it gave me chills it was
the creepiest thing I'd ever seen I was
kind of like boy if that was being
really run by FBI that's election
interference and interference in the
operations of a journalist organization
the the journalists themselves are
behaving in really weird Behavior I mean
when you imagine journalists get
together to talk about how not to cover
an issue or how to kind of squelch an
issue you know so that by the time the
Hunter buying laptop came out they had
all been mentally programmed to view it
as this information
I have still just because of other
things I still have not yet reached out
to the people involved in that tabletop
exercise to ask them what the [__] was
going on because they need to be asked
for so long way of answering questions
Francis but but I'm
um I don't think that this is over at
all I do think we're still at the very
beginning I think there's a lot of work
here for historians for journalists for
media critics and others you know I I
even my own reporting I have to go back
and re-read my Twitter files to remember
there's so many details there's so many
things that you discover later so no I
think we're at the very beginning it's
it's I think it's very exciting too
because you know Elon who obviously I
don't agree with on everything is still
making those Twitter files available so
more searches are still possible yeah
and Michael I want to move on to to
Davos the WF and the gray reset and all
that but before we do one final question
just on the journalism side of things
I I'm not naive as naive as I was five
years ago when we started the show
and yet I still thought this story
coming out would get massive coverage in
the mainstream media around the world
and I looked they and I put it on my
Twitter and to the tweets were very
popular because I think a lot of people
felt the same
day after day Twitter files after
Twitter files I would look on the BBC
the telegraph the times the guardian the
all the big newspapers in the UK and a
lot of the ones in the United States and
they would talk about you know Elon Musk
fired some cleaners who were upset now
the you know here's 10 cool things you
didn't know about Elon Musk and whatever
but not one of them covered the Twitter
files at all how is that possible how
did that happen are the three of us
insane are we are we The Crazy Ones are
we obsessed about this stuff that no one
cares about is that what's happening
here because either I am insane or
something seriously weird's going on
here no I mean you're I mean not only
that but there was some polling done by
Harvard
um around the Twitter file so first of
all
the shocking thing is how many people
did hear about the Twitter files despite
it not being in the news media on my
Twitter thread which was
um not the biggest but one of the top
biggest ones a hundred million people
viewed it and I was like when I was at
Christmas with my family I was like yeah
100 million people read my Twitter
thread and not one of them is in my
family
literally like nobody in my like
literally like nobody in my family knew
about the Twitter phones even though I
had done it and I had already sent it
out to my email it just literally so you
kind of go who's censoring what
I mean my Progressive friends and family
are are censoring
and then the news media are censoring
you know um and you know it was covered
in the Washington Post very dismissively
um just sort of saying that we that
there was nothing new here
um you know that we always knew there
was content moderation or Michael
Schellenberg was a legend of conspiracy
and there's no evidence of a conspiracy
um you know as opposed to like you know
I'm very clear I'm not saying I have
proof I'm saying there's a pattern of of
events and information that is extremely
suspicious and merits further
investigation
um and then of course they say these
investigations are just witch hunts um
so yeah I mean it's it's it's shocking
we should continue to be outraged I
think it's a permanent feature now of
the media environment that that there's
this level of fragmentation and and
censorship and you know like I mentioned
this Columbia journalism review article
about Russia gate that came out
yesterday media haven't written about
that either I suspect they won't
um and so I think that older journalism
which was attempting to be fair and
objective and give um voice to both
sides is really gone and that to the
extent to which people want diversity in
their media diet they just have to get
it from from different Outlets
Davos is a grift and a cult but it's
also a bid for global domination
[Music]